este lunes se lleva a cabo la última
ronda de negociaciones en esta segunda
fase de diálogo entre el gobierno del
presidente nicolás maduro y los
representantes de los partidos de la
oposición de venezuela en un hotel de la
ciudad de mexico desde las 11 de la
mañana la delegación gubernamental
encabezada por el líder de la asamblea
jorge rodríguez llegó para su encuentro
con la delegación opositora encabezada
por gerardo blyde cabe señalar que la
víspera del presidente maduro en una
entrevista concedida en venezuela' dijo
que han puesto sobre la mesa dos
documentos uno que tiene que ver con
devolver de inmediato al pueblo
venezolano el oro las cuentas bancarias
y los activos que han sido decomisados y
uno segundo para que la mesa de mexico
emita un pronunciamiento sobre los
derechos de los venezolanos sobre la
guayana esequiba
este último día de negociaciones se ha
visto quizá enrarecido por las
declaraciones hechas la víspera por
maduro en el sentido de que esta mesa de
negociación en mexico no implica
impunidad para juan guaidó y para todos
los opositores que tanto daño han hecho
dijo al pueblo venezolano y qué era el
día en que se haga justicia encontrará
este juan guaidó desde sus redes
sociales respondió que precisamente por
eso están luchando en las calles para
que se haga justicia en venezuela se
garantice la libertad y la democracia le
recordó a maduro que es él quien tiene
señalamientos ante la corte penal
internacional y hasta una recompensa
para su entrega es así como se
desarrolla esta negociación de los
venezolanos en la ciudad de mexico y se
espera que al concluir este último día
de discusiones se den a conocer los
acuerdos que hayan alcanzado